[Music]
I was watching the highlight reel of
tension tension
uh NASA's what's his name that's a call
that's watching tension the Sevilla and
well first of all before you start the
podcast like this Brian's referring to
the guy that Floyd marrow that's gonna
fight he's about to pee that's right I
was about to say thank you filling the
gaps yes tension the cigar car nostril
Cola who he can he can put his heat feet
and hands and knees together and elbows
together pretty well
been doing since he's about four years
old Scott who have been right well he
has big news for bought in Thailand and
he's a monster a monster he's a huge
prospect over there Hugh huge right
young kid South Paul ridiculous kicks
it's unbelievable and I'm watching and
I'm and I and my co-star Ajay Machado is
a young lady who was watching it cuz oh
my god she saw the guy she died oh yeah
the guy's a genius and look what he's
doing watch this and I'm I would call it
genius she goes to me so were you a
really good fighter she said to you yeah
and I how happy were you know well I I
pause Glenn I wouldn't say really good
that but I was good that's all I wanted
to say that's all I want to say you did
I want to say you know what I said I go
I wasn't a fighter I had to does she go
what she was like but you talk about it
so much and I ran well that's because
nobody around me is a fighter so I go in
those good knowing those who talk about
it that way and that was oh
he's stupid this kid yeah I can't just
be to use his techniques when I box me I
I just don't see Floyd's not at his age
and his undefeated record he's like you
know look you let me just go down to
[ __ ] Japan or Tokyo and just get
starts by this young up-and-comer well
the rules would have to be you just box
he's not is he's gonna let him kick I
think there's no way he's gonna kick and
if they do agree to that you should be
super skeptical hippo eyes and there's
some foul play going it's gotta be right
yeah there's gotta be and then the rules
gonna be boxing but with MMA gloves I
would assume right
which this you know this kid probably
has in those rules a better chance than
Conor McGregor sure he's a more stand-up
background yeah yeah yeah I'm more
decorated now he's super young southpaw
how old is he he's guy he's only 20 he's
20 looks every bit of 16 years old yeah
you can never tell with those guys chin
doesn't look 41 I'm pausing because hat
looks 13 now it's it there is something
to be said about when you're hairless I
don't hear listen oh right you're gonna
tend to look you've zero here huh yeah
yeah that tends to be I just call foul
play with this fight you have to there's
something going on it I would everyone
got all upset I to it that last I went
if you think this fights legit then you
probably love macho man versus Ultimate
Warrior yeah about as legit as that
speaking of hairless I know you probably
saw my Instagram when I was with Tariq
did you not see that huh oh why don't
you why don't you bring it up cuz some
will target or acknowleding I'll explore
work is not here list no he's not but he
looks good I've ever seen him in by the
way he looks he looks very good he's
good he looks great but why don't you
take a look at this this this video that
we just when was this this is it
breakfast on a Sunday morning in San
Francisco down at the Ferry Building and
you know how crowded it is down there on
a Sunday right what time we guys there
um 9:30 10:00 this is actually I'll say
exactly was this was about 10:20 because
I I had to catch my flight and I always
push it to the last minute so this was
yeah so guy didn't play this okay but
they could
what the [ __ ] that oh that's legal in
Sanford uh-huh how did you guys not get
closer you a shot of his [ __ ] as long as
you're wearing a [ __ ] ring I don't
consider it nudity does he have one hon
decorate he had a [ __ ] ring
I shouldn't say [ __ ] we saw a guy like
that like why our first show there yes
no me I was skinnier younger yes this
this guy had a ring around the base so
it was pushing him everything but
everything was cinched up that's the way
you got to do but he levers jangling
around at least he was wearing a hat and
he had a briefcase yeah
like what the [ __ ] goes on in your head
is going to [ __ ] it what goes on in your
head that you could just like I mean
like it gonna be full crazy look at this
can we not can you zoom in on him chin
even get a little blurry look at him
walking in a bush no he did not speak to
you that's why I said think about that I
said speaking of hairless he was well
well manicured down there he had almost
no hair now at the best buddy ever seen
no think of the nerve to put on socks
well he's got with those shoes yeah he's
got an butt-naked
there's the dick he's wearing shoes and
that's incredible leather briefcase I
assume uh yes it wasn't as expensive it
looked like an expensive man purse you
know what maybe some [ __ ] Rick rich
[ __ ] tech billionaire he's just like
you know why who gives a [ __ ] then I got
[ __ ] you money why are you wearing
clothes around everybody I'm not like
everybody let me go and buy a diamond
studded [ __ ] ring and stroll around San
Fran my friend Whitney has made lots of
lots of money he's got his own hedge
fund and he likes now because he's bored
at my age to do these endurance races
and then he does tough mudders and then
he decided to do this very special Navy
SEAL course for it's like they put you
through hell week for a week fun they
don't let you sleep and they push you
and all that okay so if you look at the
I looked at the finalists he made it but
all he does is train for that stuff okay
so it was him and about and five other
dudes all of whom were either in their
40s or in their 50s [ __ ]
wealthiest [ __ ] but all of them looked
in shape really good shape then there
was the one guy that beat
all of them and he looked like a pair he
looked like a pair yeah and and he had
and I said what's with that guy he goes
well that guy beat all of us the
mentally he's alone he's a billionaire
he goes well he's a billionaire and his
brain his mind is much stronger he can
just shut this everything out quit in
this yeah he can shut everything out
yeah and and and I guess he watches
himself go through the like he pulls
himself out of his body and watches
himself isn't that weird yeah that's
what they say the Buddhists do when they
like a flow state yeah weird like the
mental and physical pain it doesn't
affect it doesn't affect those guys like
that in sports the great one I'm sure
right love the great one yeah like those
Navy SEALs like yes they're there
everyone goes out to their pain
threshold it's like no they don't that's
not even a factor right like campaigns
the same way like yeah how he can go for
thousands of miles
everyone else quits yeah there's just
something they well they they can
apparently they can step outside of
themselves and observe the pain so they
they detach from it in a so Buddhist
like so so the guys in Vietnam who
protests the war the Buddhist monk who
lit himself on fire bring up the picture
of that for a second it's an intense pic
it's an intense picture and he didn't
make any noise he protested the war set
himself on fire in front of I think in
Saigon I think I think in front of the
whatever it was and never really he
never look at that he never moved
he just groaned and fell over what and
he died and he died but it was a way of
protesting but talk about the power of
someone's mind he was able to literally
holy look at that out of him yes 1963
talk about a statement luck
oh and protest of the war in protest of
he doesn't get up and run no he took it
didn't scream they just he just released
air from his body and fell over did now
that's my control did everyone freaked
out well he see the monks behind him
there that was a that was a planned
protest how did it help anything
I think it did the war still go on it
did but I think it was images like that
that were so iconic for
mara know for sure where we all went
well we all went that I'm talking about
it now and it was a it was a sign of
true resistance peaceful resistance a
terrible war yes oh it did actually is
it peaceful no it did and I'll tell you
why it's swayed American public opinion
things like this that the population
itself was against the war with Vietnam
yes well that was a nasty war yeah yeah
it was but look at that oh look at the
[ __ ] look at them wearing and the
saffron robe is is signifies celibacy so
you have renounced our money and said
yeah no no nut November they do no not
life they do not like no no no not
November is no nut life for this guy no
not November in go [ __ ] yourself Wow
silver October you mean life bro it's my
life yeah for a couple of us for a
couple gal not November you can take
that and shove it that's right that's
right I like my food I like the Matteo
I like the nut and I like my coffee I
like my nuts in my Tiffani I like my
food I like to nut and I like my coffee
okay but the key word there not know hey
what kind of what kind of door to pull
back to Bernie can you go I go back to
there where the guys bowing to him right
there he died right there go back to
yeah look at that and that that's that's
the guy bowing to him Jesus look at
these guys all sitting that's powerful
[ __ ] for reals now back to no not
November no that's crazy
let's talk about nuts so I'm trying to
say hey what kind of Thank You Jane look
up though we're the no nut November
started what kind of [ __ ] did the
dork was like you know white boys
everyone's doing sober October no not
November let's put a stop to see what
see what Robert Frank six one five has
to say he's crazy enough I want to know
where it came I said I'll never mind it
it's got crime and then you find out
where this came from chin who originated
this because I'm a punch him in the dick
this guy
[Music]
if you expecting it were you ain't
begging you ain't no [ __ ] man hey
Billy I have a swell idea we're cool
look please slide about the end I'll
give you a night to remember
cuz when it comes to sex I weigh more
than 3-hundred bowler when I beg you
over and on your shoulder oh my god
[ __ ] like awesome awesome robert
frank 6:15 god bless athil there's God
he's yeah where did this come from
it is a such a beta male move man well
wasn't it I thought in fighting you must
know fighters that decide not to nut is
know that boxers always are you from the
fort yeah in the 40s then science came
out with hold on wait by you guys not
busted nut your lorne your testosterone
because we're less nuts yes when you
stop us nuts your body goes alright
let's not make this not produced anymore
they're not using it lowers your
testosterone I don't know about habits
five-hour gangbang before world title
fight but just normal sex is healthy for
a fight it keeps your telly distension
and actually boo [ __ ]
testosterone ha now I'm not saying
[ __ ] again not a 7-hour power [ __ ]
where my legs are all pins right you're
sweating thrown out your back when I was
in New Orleans on a parade float for
Mardi Gras I was with the New Orleans
Saints and I was talking to this giant
african-american middle linebacker and I
said Who I go hey do you ever like
refrain from sex before a game or like
you know a month before and he goes what
he does look like good that [ __ ] out ya
know it's not the 70s I don't know
anyone who does that yeah this guy goes
too stretchy this is
buddy one thirty year old man named Alex
told the publication he decide that
every time he felt the porn urge he
would instead study Spanish and goes now
I'm nearly fluent in it yeah take that
sexual energy and put it into Spanish it
says there are currently over 35
neurological studies that show that
pornographic porno can lead to brain
changes and negative side effects that
can impact sexual health I don't watch
porn anymore
I'm bored with it I swear to god I'm
telling you not only say you're a liar
although you're full of no I don't I
really don't [ __ ] I really don't I swear
to God
last time I watched porn is I don't
remember I swear to God it was last
night but the point is this full lift no
I really don't do you watch a lot of it
not a ton I usually use the guy's
already boarding I know it's so lame
dude I mean you should do no no November
and get the [ __ ] out the studio what
yeah are you being sarcastic right now
no pornos disgusting the way they treat
those women no it just doesn't get me
going anymore I don't know I need I need
something specific so I can do it I'm
just telling you the station takes a
holiday no not November I just I do that
periodically all the time I really do
I keep myself you're full of [ __ ] thank
you I call it keeping my Dimond there's
nice days that's why I have so much
energy and I'm so clear-headed it's a
wonder who is the first time this is a
social media phenom man phenomenon I
would have just gained steam online and
then people like yeah let's do it we're
not having it out so people are doing
you know what this is I just like people
that the words crying you better vote
look what happens if you don't vote and
then one vote and comes down it comes
out they do well those are my favorite
people yeah you guys all vote tomorrow
take a picture and post the picture I
will
cuz that's what the trump vote was very
interesting I thought yeah I did know I
know I always work it's very tough to
follow your logic there Donald Trump
yeah I think it's funny but more more
and more people coming out to the voting
you know the polls but I'd be curious
how
people doin own up November it's gonna
be tough to find real stats on that it's
not a real [ __ ] can't be in the
bedroom all the time
you don't like Brogan talked I was like
sober October they obviously didn't
start that people have been doing this
forever sober October what is the
moustache mo vember same thing I've ever
seems to be there so grow a mustache be
sober and don't not know no chance ever
you grow a mustache no note me
November's not sober that's only October
people get [ __ ] up in the hot November
the holidays what's December is anything
in December why is it every month have a
cool one what do you call those then I
call all the other months social [ __ ]
December [ __ ] a lot January bang till
you drop February
what did there but they're all not
social media things Jen October is not
social me so where'd you call it the cat
holiday themes are monthly holiday
themes I got nothing Oh monthly holiday
challenges sure maybe we should do one
maybe the whole team here chef doing
let's see if there's any cooler December
challenges to me how about not saying
the f-word that'd be tough for me
strength for the reason water every day
wake up every day between 4:00 or 5:00
check do you lastin read any news all
right avoid all sugar oh it's a tough
one exercise it says hard anything can
check worked my fire straight terrible
idea
I don't public space every day I'm in a
park suck this dick to two hours with
yourself every day for a week
[ __ ] off keep going is that it that's it
got a stupid list drink water sit in a
park by yourself and work out you know
it's a good technique for real
but it's still and not move a muscle for
ten minutes it's better to do
self-improvement January is February
plaque history month so take it easy and
April got I wonder if there's late fall
in April grateful in April April God
none of them really catching on minds
over October's huge and Movember that's
all I can think of
dry and July what is it dry July no
alcohol first I feel like a lot of those
things are for P middle in the summer
what are you crazy
I'm feeling a lot no president December
people who generally don't live a very
disciplined life yeah right yeah well
it's the same thing like in January when
is their New Year's resolution everyone
else they get in shape and now the my
gyms are all crowded and they're crowded
for about three weeks that's that then
and after that people start to fizzle
away yeah it's like why would you wait
to January first to start working out
right and start a diet but I also like
tell people like I have people I've had
recently I had somebody come up to me
and ask me how I stay in shape and I
said I want what's your advice and I was
like well let's see you're you've been
living this way for close to 50 years I
was like I do only thing I would say is
if you're gonna try to exercise and it's
a disciplinary thing and it's like
you've got to figure out a way to make
it enjoyable like you you know it's for
it to be sustainable there's somebody
hated workout yeah how many ways you
like out like I go through fit like my
peloton bike I ride every week but
there's times let's do it seven days a
week and I love it I'm obsessed with it
and then I get bored of that then I go
to box and you mix it up lasses then I
get bored with both of those then I'll
work with my trainer one then while
you're both bored with all three of
those here then I start running outside
yeah when my knees start to hurt my
back's like Ronnie Coleman then I go
back to the peloton mhm
that's right just mix it up but it's got
to be fun it's got to make you feel good
if you if you if you hate it that much
my father has an issue because when he
grew up he was poor and he had to do a
lot of manual labor construction and
[ __ ] and wake up really early and so
whenever he has to exercise or even
[ __ ] change a lightbulb in the house
it reminds him of when he was poor as a
kid so in July blow it you can't get him
if you say to him if you say to him I'm
being serious if you say to him since I
kid hey can you help me move this table
he'll do it but he is he mad he moves he
moves at a glacial pace Sam he can't say
[ __ ] you did
hey dad hand me a fork mmm the [ __ ] just
say to me now what are you saying yeah I
heard I worked well he was working
construction he was doing two jobs and
when he was 25 he had a heart attack
from stress the muscles are not his
heart contracted is this yeah
so that's carve [ __ ] he did as a kid so
when he was you know he had to do that
until he was like 25 being on the
Marines and all that but he just can't
stand it he can't stand physical and
eating physical there's drop up dropped
over but that's basically silver October
you're gonna lose weight November
Movember I can't just grow in the
mustache yeah well you can't grow the
mustache because you [ __ ] someone in
here do Cara don't do Movember
chin do Movember I haven't mustache all
the time Judd but just them but don't
shave it dude I look like I've let it
grow grow I look so comfy awesome your
bets a comfort nope they do it so you
look like every stereotypical bad guy in
a kung fu movie now oh and wear that
beanie you're talking about a foo Manchu
Manchu man come on bro
that could be you yes yes that's a white
guy by the way that's this nation wow
this is nice yeah well you know when I
when I [ __ ] grow a mustache I look
like I need to stay away from high
schools I don't look good there are
pictures of me online with a mustache
yeah there we did a Mini Cooper
commercial with that I did and that
didn't look so bad
well the 80s vibe being healthy mothers
at 80s vibe but I their eye on that TV I
would wear our shame you down to do that
or I'll do it
yes well then if you go but what do you
shave it like donating this kind of
discus no what do you do with it go back
to that list you had that's about
Movember I think you just brings
awareness to dick cancer let me just
look up the real mustache you registered
and get cancer on your dick by the way
money goes to men's health programs and
oh yes for men's health I do remember
that
interesting what do they do with the
money mm mm the magazine men's health
I probably donate to someone else I
think don't they good if there was a fun
when I'd be down to do it I still want
to do a Spartan Race or our long ass
[ __ ] uh it's par on something yeah I
probably will never do that
brand up for you you know I'd be worried
about you going from hot to cold
temperatures that you're eight I'd be
honest well I appreciate that but I can
weather that [ __ ] like nobody's beeswax
will do it and I will no I'll get into a
hot I'll get it I've done that before
did you know what Tough Mudder stuff
yeah I was before but I'm so out of
shape right now bro I throw you can
ready for the biggest fight of your life
you haven't talked about it forever
I saw out-of-shape green shot Shaq and
shake every day Shaq Shaq and Shake bro
you know I've just been I just haven't
been taking care of myself I should yeah
what you been doing bro into drugs no
man he's an artist yes that's exactly
what it is I work on other stuff cat I
feel like you'd be down for a Spartan
Race yeah I've always wanted to do I'd
be just me we'd look like real good I
look like Ren and Stimpy yep you're all
yep Ren and Stimpy
you know Wrentham I think would be cool
of you yeah I think you'd be cool if you
carried me on your back when I was tired
it'd be so dramatic and romantic it'd be
like I can't go on anybody till you
doing it I can't man get on my back I
throw my back out didn't [ __ ]
you wouldn't carry me if I was we were
naked and afraid and I'd cut my foot
I'll put your three-piece on my back and
figure it out there you go when it's hot
and it's like you're just worried about
food there's there's no gayness bro like
I could put you on my shoulders your
dick could be slumped on my shoulder
like a bladder and I could be talking
about dude I'm so tired it would not
matter it doesn't matter when you're in
that state of mind I know I would like
take myself out of my body and I just
looked down and it's not gay it was like
when I was playing cactus quills out of
Rogen's ass and leg I were in the
wilderness survival I'd love to do a
Spartan
Muhtar I hit up because you know how I
work with that Robin on peloton I only
use her classes Robin NYC Robin NYC
she's like my favorite instructor on
that she's such a badass she was a
lawyer now she runs like 100-mile
marathons
she's such about us so I only take her
class usually the only one with hip hop
too but she's also the best instructor
on there
look at that Leone shape she [ __ ] guy
yeah Mary Brian just got married so I
need you to pump the brakes
whose jacket ah caught me also it's no
nut November just caught me [ __ ]
right it just caught me off-guard bro
she was sticking her tongue out and I
was like what the [ __ ] but I told her
I'm in New York end of the month I'm
gonna come to the headquarters and get
my ass the most winning is winning is a
person in tough matters Amelia she dates
Tim Ferriss Amelia she's on a cover of
she beats all the men she's also you
know all she does when she's not winning
the beating everybody in the world that
it means one of us does
Amelia Boone check her out okay right
there she's she crushes everybody all
men and everything
she's also a full-time lawyer at Apple
jeez yeah I had Apple yes and Tim said
like sometimes she'll be like just drop
me off here and he's like but we're 23
miles when she'll run through the woods
and get there and then and then join him
for a workout she's on a different level
a completely different level of anybody
else and they do you look at her and she
looks pretty normal
just that mental game son yeah look at
her like really pretty yeah she's not
bad and I'll go can go forever beats all
the men there are no men that because
what she said hmm interesting
yeah she's shocking she's shocking dad
see I could I'm so big enough to leave
so much weight to compete in marathons
and stuff but it's not for you the
endurance you you know dance is my thing
you can do it and endurance is my thing
yeah but you're so big that I don't
think you'd beat the skinnier smaller
people you know the I don't know I mean
I don't before a big if there's a
heavyweight class your endurance my it
was always mine yeah but you're gonna be
an go forever right
but the smaller of course Mahler's are
gonna move faster well didn't you do a
mountain thing you did like or the
military thing we just carried a bunch
it and kind of broke I've heard broke
some records yep that's big that's crazy
long girls usually the betters for me in
fights - I never let's fight past first
round Wow you just can't
your training or genetics it both I
guess both yeah so can you run
can you run ten miles all right now in a
price the great I can rent their mouth
yeah I bike at least ten to fifteen
miles every day do your and then when I
run I'm gonna use around six or seven so
when you run to your feet give out or no
nothing gives out my knee can get a
little tricky if I do it back-to-back
days right this left knee nothing stem
cells can't fix though bro so I'm
reached out to me to hook it up you
bumped it and you you ran into a fire
hydrant this we talk with our friend
tark in San Francisco yeah and was like
yeah check that out your goose ran right
into a fire hydrant I can't feel good
got it [ __ ] my knees well fire hydrants
don't have a lot of give you mean no I
mean that's not her if you got fire
hydrant like-kind even when the car hits
it kind of say 500 pounds or something
crazy there Dicky's yeah there's the
thickest thing out there yeah they're
all cast-iron you don't want to run into
a fire he's not a good idea how about
that gunshot after our last show we're
you know we're in the green room all in
good mood there's a broom like there the
windows are open to the street we're all
playing have a good time playing
grab-ass and reg1 just Stalin right
inside disco [ __ ] right the Bay Area
very normal you know what I saw one was
so excited about my show there's it
going yeah it was like going commander
honor it was these Russians but ya know
show how do how about what I did what I
do is I because I'm naturally have my
default is to be a hero I go get down
and I threw my spotty on leaning on me I
saved him you kicked that girl with the
blonde a sweat move [ __ ] move [ __ ] and
it all on me kept reading get down down
get the money bad jump fell on me fell
on you
I owe my entire career to him you felt
it he can't die though if he goes I go I
said that if he goes my career screw to
no have I said that part he goes there's
no fire in the kid man come on there was
like dude calm down yeah I got a little
I got a little I don't know I was it
looked like I was saving you
that's what happened you hit my brother
in the face away and then there was
nothing it was actually a blow back in
the car so we're fine but we figured out
your real motives and it was all right
listen man I got bills bro I hear you
man
you keep running the business no I do
maestro put the mic no no thank you
how good shows we had some good shows in
Cobbs this job was fun that was fun one
of the best right hacked it in sold that
every show jobs is a good one dude yeah
it's a table table table that's a really
good room yeah you know even though it
was hot the room was hot and by the time
last show the hands hot yeah but you
know but but it was still good they were
still yeah it's always if it's a hot if
it's hot and late yeah it's a bad combo
comedy mama a little bit hot late
drinking yeah yeah little fidgety there
was an octave I was watching you from
the balcony and there was a guy in front
of me and he smelled like weed he was
laughing she was like he loved that
people I was dying I was like this guy's
[ __ ] like you'd go like this you'd be
in the between jokes and he'd go like
this he go Jesus he wind up with she's
on token maybe covering up
I was like dude you got a [ __ ] calm
down thank God he was sitting up and
about oh my god I think it'll be tracked
it's like who brought the hyena sir
muzzle you're a hyena please it was
crazy at some lady at the mean Greek
trying to suck on my neck
really now was she missing all her teeth
yeah maybe she was broken she was was
she hammered sure her band's gonna lease
I'm dude I'm so sorry yeah
I'm so sorry there's always at least one
time every other weekend where a drunk
very depressed housewife will have my
don't grab my Tom yeah well reach out go
gank
yeah I could have a few me too yeah
yeah boy like let them take the picture
and then they resound like oh no we
can't do that you know it was sucked on
my neck on come on come on dude yeah
like yeah would you do that to anybody
else what he's sucking on my neck Wow
cuz she wanted some of that neck neck
you brought up the funky it in her even
though she has no teeth so she's always
thirsty for blood when she just can't
get it when she tries to get her teeth
in it sounds like gunk gunk think you
know this all you do is he'd get gummed
by than you are no you know it feels
like you know those fish that suck on
the tank that eat the algae they're like
black but they just suck all day that's
what she was punished by the vampire
council she probably broke some vampire
rule and they little dirtied and he
pulled her teeth and actually haha
you're really funny yeah I used to have
one of those as a kid suck suck suck
that's what she looked like suck on the
snack cool you remind me of a fish I
owned as a kid
hmm do you know what that suck all the
[ __ ] off the side of the tank you look
like that he looked like a soccer face
there cool man you'd have them there's
like little they just whack your tank
for your cue they just stand there what
they got in the algae oh that's how they
do if you had like three of them your
tank was clean all the time and no one
fights them that's all they do is suck
Oh their entire life I saw one of those
Mexican hairless dogs and it didn't have
it and so I this woman's like this is my
dog and and the dog didn't have I well
the dogs tongue was hanging all the way
out and I was like dog I go his tongue
and she goes he didn't own any teeth I
was like ah so cool your dog has no
teeth and no hair you must be great
damn ginger changes put masks in here
yes any and then goes whoops yeah
they're cool little man they feel like a
nut sack yeah they do they feel like a
big nut sack of bones yep a big nut sack
I want to hear this dog you do yeah the
hairs killing me mental are you get
allergies it's just annoying can't wear
black ant yeah there it is that's
exactly what I saw wow I'm pretty sure
that the dog just like they got voted
ugliest dog in the world
I think he's cute but that Tom there is
yeah he got atarax on that play he got
nothing he got voted number one
I feel like if you like tripped on me
break his neck yeah those dogs get taken
by Eagles and when you're in Alaska
that's when I was in Alaska fishing some
Mexican these Mexican woman brought her
little white dog and the guide said
please keep her dog on a leash and she
didn't keep her dog on a leash and a
bald eagle and took that [ __ ] dog and
flew away with her dog and she never saw
her dog again
well don't bring your stupid dog -
laughs she was so traumatized they had
to bring her to the hospital because it
was her dog she loved her dog lucky it
wasn't you bit and that's why I try to
always shoot that's why it will always
shoot Oh Bob's coming I go I'm doing dog
control yellow snatch some dogs bro
there you go that's the kind of dog it
was a white fluffy one I wasn't there
but she what did you do this weekend
dude um just had some friends over what
when the [ __ ] no friends over for what
just hang up visit house visiting from
out of town yeah
where are they from they're from where
you guys are at see em friends that
friend you met her Joanne oh yeah did
they stay with you stayed with me just
her just her yeah play some music
there's some music did she say I'm gonna
I'm gonna just get changed and I guess
I'll sleep on the cap do you have a
coach I do have a couch you went okay I
could I'm gonna be in my king bed yeah
I'll just be on the left side there is
room but sure and don't mind me I'm just
gonna play some music oh very my pants
off yeah nothing your homies were all
we're just homies yeah yeah well yeah
I'm not gonna let us sleep on the couch
tonight definitely watch the fights you
do watch the fights yeah Tim no they she
left on Saturday evening but I want to
create time did the whole thing
karaoke Dre did you post stuff yeah show
it to me
I think it's gone already I put on my
story boy yeah oh yeah you can get it
from your archives and you really yeah
tag is on it karaoke no well what's it
what were you singing
Lana Ritchie hello
I know I just don't selling someone DME
like Yoo si Jin singing like no why
don't you post on your regular [ __ ] dude
it's just so you know I was drunk I wish
you could pull it off oh you're a
hammered yeah so I'll just keep it
show it let it go let it disappear you
were you you were hammered all weekend
man why so a hammer dude
cuz we're just celebrating celebrating
to dull the training out you're
celebrating friendship
yeah friendship take some food dick and
booze no brain I can cop for murder
yeah what's the guy from San Francisco
party there's no guy oh there's another
big not big tall white girl oh don't say
big tall she heard it now yeah I know by
tall white girl do you mean white guy
with a wig can't you just worked
yep worked bought the fights for certain
residents oh yeah yeah lit up all their
guests did you call every fight it's
close what you say about Weidman Jacare
I don't know if I did call that one I'm
sure I took Weidman probably I was wrong
he said your heart or something like
that
yeah tough fight for white boots i down
was tough to call cos Weidman had such a
long way off mmm-hmm but yeah DC called
mister round hit third round rear naked
choke second round that's a branch one
called branch lost you I took a cannon
in there yes we watched that together he
looks like his unbelievable yeah
unbelievable
I think the only guy who's gonna give
him real real problems with the blue
area I don't think he'd be favored would
be Luke Rockhold yeah I'd be a car's
life-form because I know big and it's
striking so good - yeah and he's a
knockout artist and his grappling is
ridiculous it's really he's just way
bigger he is waiting like he is bigger
huh just like well cyber stopped under
those six four hours I was saying he's
very rock holds taller and media yeah
that would be the only five be a little
worried front but again stop bend over
to have a speed advantage so it's not an
awful fight for him
unless Luke Rockhold decides to take him
down how about butts table burners
takedown defense looked really fun
looked amazing no he looked amazing
um the question is yeah I was like
stomping a community and you reminded me
of a guy named yo Romero and Whittaker
how would he do against Whitaker that's
a good question
see I wouldn't be surprised if they if
he just jumped the queue and they made
him fight the win of Whittaker gasps all
gasp them because they knew they could
do an all oceanic fight whether it's in
New Zealand or right there both from
there so yes diverse in that'd be a huge
fight yeah that's a great mat inverse
Whitaker's a phenomenal matchup amazing
matchup but though I bet to make him
fight one I bet he'll fight jock ray or
Yeo reum ill I feel like style benders
pure striking in my higher level than
would occur right I mean because it's
it's almost different different I'm what
in MMA Whitaker has obviously better
knockouts
yeah he looks good Whitakers boxing is
probably better but overall yes now
bender has better credentials but as far
as UFC wins right I mean I'm close
Whitaker yeah mr. Chan yep beat some
[ __ ] you meet yo Romero twice yeah he
starched dr. a starched up crazy
no he's Whitaker's a monster man but his
injuries he doesn't fight that often he
gets hurt has a huge fight gets hurt
he's out he also did you know that that
fight with John Romero took was a war he
took a lot of damage in that fight a lot
he's tough as it gets but [ __ ] yeah I'm
really curious to see stiii if I had to
put all my money on it because it's
tough hold a style bender Bertie I think
he's 29
there's a lot of experience though yeah
but I mean that's why he's got a lot of
fun a bank on him yeah I Bank on him to
be yeah because he's not like a really
young kid who's just getting
catapulted to the top like he has a
background yes so he's 29
yeah I feel like he's a guy 29 yeah yeah
29 he's coming into his own and that's
either a shitload of fights I mean he is
he was a dick Ulis record it was 32 I
know for his amateur career and then
yeah he's a ton of fight experience man
yeah seventy five and six and
it bugs me again though we had we seen
this takedown defense but houses you
know is wrestling with a guy like
Rockhold be a liability in a few
different but Bronson's more decorated
collegiate wrestler Ruckle dent
wrestling college but Rockhold's just
he's just get it everything yes he's
very tall the the boobs beaded Ronson
looked like his takedowns were like that
that he was kind of like that crouching
single he always leans that's Brunson's
always but he fine he only loses the
very best Brunson's a [ __ ] man
yep she jumped some current event yeah
guys ready for him just hard go for it
all right cat so post Malone had a
collab with Crocs and they sold out why
with the [ __ ] would he collab with Crocs
I don't know it doesn't really make
sense but looking at the picture I think
it makes sense he seems like the type of
guy who would wear Crocs usually has
like some pretty good style like sweg
east i like he asked his kind of grunge
hip-hop vibe style
I mean Crocs are terrible dude they're
just terrible
there's no be a lease ah they're awful
listen post mom could come out with
named anything anything it's gonna sell
out anything anything I mean it did
proves it Crocs living Crocs did this as
like a one last attempt to save their
business they're going out like we're
cool we're actually they're not going
out of business like no that that's a
that's not true people think they are
but they're not they they reinforced ORS
work and stuff but they're actually
crushing it and there was this rumor
that they were going on business and
then this guy was talking about how
they're they're actually there's the guy
better guy in the show dude I've
listened to a guy who in the shoe
business he's like absolutely they're
their profits had never been higher
looked at up chin it's easier to look
ups he was right here quatre Brian one
of you are lying one of you were lying
um because I would assume they suck
mmm-hmm
Crocs is closing manufacturing facility
but we'll keep making shoes Crocs
sparked a minor panic among fans clogs
by announcing on Wednesday that the
company is closing the last of its
manufacturing facilities the foot banker
because Muller which can rest easy the
foot we're making isn't going out of
business it's doing better it's it's
doing better and severed it done
actually it doesn't say that yeah but
the guy was talking about it and I'm
telling you he knows because he's in the
business I'm you need to verify your
sources being you know there's last year
the thanks for trustee Mann was well no
that's doing 17b I know but I talked to
a guy who knows I was listening to him
talk unless he's lying for some weird
reason well people tell me [ __ ] all the
time though you know this is guy who's
manufacturing clothing shoe business
profits rose 54% nobody missed my point
John 14 but this is after they reported
that their stores impose their shutting
down as 54% just takes low annual sales
exceed a billion dollars six consecutive
years comfortable as [ __ ] geez the other
should be set yeah in the most recent
quarter I 160 stores so that was why
people like to wear your closing 160
stores stores aren't really the right
it's the online sales I don't know a
single person wears cross well I think a
lot of people wear them like dentists
and doctors like hospitals and then the
baby boy his mom's house mom's I sister
and my boyfriend love crock I was
wearing them in a long time and they
would it so easy to wear theirs okay but
don't they make other styles they make
the see-through sneakers the kids wear
I'm a lot by the way
huge children's business no kids we're I
think I forget what my son wears them
they're they're similar than I'm talking
about right there not quite yet but
they're they're not those
yeah there's there are so there are
tennis shoes they're like tennis but
there you can see through right yeah
well there's like hold by someone yes my
so you playing rivers and yes I feel
what they're called
those are Crocs those are
cross I forget what those water socks
are they they're not [ __ ] old like I
don't see a lot of Crocs actually not
see-through shoes no kids if you type in
top kid shoes is gonna come in top
kitchen yeah guarantee it they're called
like skins are alive years ago what are
those those are it natives I actually
like those like way better than crowd I
would look like shocks they can wear to
do whatever yeah listen as those in gray
yellow blue red maybe I'll wear em you
basically wear those those those boots
though they're [ __ ] cooler cuz they
just put them on and do work yep yep
but the Crocs just I remember when Crocs
first came out there they might have
started in Boulder but who ever was
we just got to our locker rooms and they
want us to be like with the first team
to wear them and they put me everyone's
lockers and it was like they're comfy
but the head I mean the black is like
what the [ __ ] I can't everyone rocked
them cuz we're in camp but after that
girl would be like grow more girls like
I am NOT alright a dick with those
Krauts on and we're like check please
yeah let's burn them I I got into in my
head about when I was 33 or saying to
start dressing stylishly I go I'm done
I'm gonna start wearing really cool
clothes and I went and bought I went and
shopped on my own and bought silk shirt
that was tea through its chest hair was
palm my girl fingers
she looks just oh my god I was just
that's the most disgusting [ __ ] sure
how embarrassing your hair you know your
hair sticking go room 13 I was like why
I look down I was like I'll take this
off dude out but this one guy on our
team Gary Moore were a size 17 oh my
went to high school them and played pop
one over them
we're size 17 years 6 8 370 pounds but
they didn't make a big enough form so
they put them in the dryer to get them
hot and then try to expanding you hot
and then what you'd wear them they look
straight up look like when you go
snorkeling like they like those black
they're shitty enough looking as they
are Ubuntu dryer and they're just hey
it's summer man play not for you though
why not for you just buy flippers
my father has a size 14 shoe but his
feet are too wide too wide and my father
all my father's ever wanted to be was a
Renaissance man and a stylish man he
wanted to be kind of Italian sir but
he's built like the letter H with giant
terrible feet and nothing is good he's
got to go to shitty stores where they
may have he's gonna [ __ ] big and tall
and stuff he can't find [ __ ] shoes
for those wide feet it's a disaster
yeah if you're a really big dude style
is tough man if you're a really big dude
though with like shaped certain way like
small waist big shoulders like you have
that but it's tough still yeah but if
you hadn't closed me if you have an
athletic build you're good you can look
good yeah but it's tough yeah I mean my
damn beating players they try they look
rough sometimes it's just like yeah it's
just it's too much cloth it's just
doesn't look appealing yes you're not
supposed to be that Gucci doesn't make a
shirt that big what are you doing Cam
Newton definitely does his best to he
kind of peacock he kind of over does it
I appreciate though it's a lot of makeup
can newton basketball players are
actually the best-dressed athletes you
dial I just he just tries just do Cam
Newton and I figure images I'm sure it's
him he's a handsome you know those those
hats that he has made is a local guy in
Venice really yep this one I although he
always wears hats every gave me were
saying that's cool he looks good good
all those that's his thing yeah always
wearing a hat yeah like if you stop
typing Cam Newton hats
it's a local Venice place Hey now he's a
giant man correct six five good looking
dude they're all in this year too
Carolina's back he's being good look at
that that's bad that's a that's a lot of
color mmm [ __ ] oh yeah looks good on
them though I don't think I only closed
it off not sure Yosemite Sam no that's
how
and this come for me so me doesn't pull
off but I appreciate the effort and it's
a lot of effort to do this that would be
that has uh you know that was a hard
pass when I was dressed like that the
hand made that looks like a dick that's
just like a hand made for Halloween a
little kid came to me because she goes
are you a lamp he looks like a lamb let
them take a lamb or one from he looks
like a lamp from Willie walk on the
problem there's Farrakhan don't with a
little type of Fez that's called the Fez
and I like the glasses Morocco
yeah you so he probably as the most
outlandish style and then FL you know as
the most outlandish town the NBA russell
westbrook beautiful come on yes oh yeah
um yes yeah fashion this style gets all
crazy whoa yes that one's not bad
smiling yeah it's not bad
tucked in well where's some outrageous
[ __ ]
damn that's an interesting look that's
like a girl's top right no one's pretty
terrible yeah it's terrible
no one's cool well that's a that's
that's a that's a data lovely skirt with
some white jeans or leggings that sperry
eyeball that looks very very feminine
kay right or feminine is ever can you
zoom in on that for a second
wow that's amazing
now easy do I have those shoes in that
jacket yes Brian but the point is I do
is he a gay man [ __ ] no Russell
Westbrook no no been made for quit
that's not really again just cuz that
outfit you've gone I mean I love it I
think it's awesome that's not my
favorite outfit there but the jackets
dope and I like the shoes I don't like
those pants keep going chin that's
outfit sick I dig that
okay same well oh that's remarkably I'm
gonna ask you again I'm gonna ask you
the question again I want you to answer
with an open mind is then finally I have
two questions one is really is he a gay
man do you know what the only thing is
here is he's been with the same girl in
high school okay could be a beard sitter
look up go Michael westbrook's wife and
been together forever and then the
second question is is he is he bicurious
they've been together forever I mean
look I don't know god bless him and I
love long-term couples it's got to be a
lot of deep love there be I get for him
right so who knows maybe cuz he's got
his girl he just loves fashion like you
do and the only bangs guys once in
awhile like you dude Leon days that in
with wine that's all nowadays and wonder
why and maybe that's the case so no nut
November that's all that's all and they
have a kid oh she's and she looks like a
strong woman Oh what else got you I'm
just saying like all right so uh there
you go so a man got attacked by fifty
aggressive seals over in the UK yeah you
know and I also joke bro if you're in
the water with him they're not now when
you say you got attacked by fifty
aggressive seals as they flopped toward
him at exactly four miles an hour yeah
this sounds like a run bro I've seen
seals on on land they move very yeah I'm
faster than the fastest seal of all time
I still could train from day one I would
start to [ __ ] see that's what I so I
don't know maybe they were moving they
were flopping in his general direction
and I'll tell you something else if a
seal did come at me I wouldn't tell
anybody I wouldn't come and say I got
attacked by a seal and you'd say watch
you'd go did you get bit what happened I
don't know but it flopped aggressively
in my direction and if they
to just turn away and walk because they
can't catch up there you go
if you walked in a slow pace it would
take days for them to get to you right
or did you look like you want to have
some fun and just start [ __ ] curbing
those stupid seals and their dumb noses
start stop okay you'll stop feeling low
kicks low kicking low kick them with
more attacking them with your shins
across that yeah what's this guy say
keep going
oh it says he called for help in several
Coast Guard teams lifeboat and police
maybe to his aides Coast Guard rescue
officer was reportedly lowered to the
man using ropes also I lift a man down
the lifeboat thankful was he in the
water no he got stranded on a cliff so
he got up on high ground so they
wouldn't be able to flop to him so you
know what he was fine he was actually
fine there apply acting in a be hey a
territorial way or they were just moving
in that direction because the Sun was
hitting the weather they're freaked out
because this random dudes all up in
their area or there's a old great white
toe in the water and they're like holy
[ __ ] man that's right we're not going
over there and then maybe I suppose he
walked up on there and then he was I
come help and the Coast Guard go OK and
they came and got him off he was rescued
from the cliff not from seals he's
probably stuck and he's like these seals
are harassing me come get me here's what
really annoys me thankfully that man was
uninjured of course he was but he did
suffer from minor cold exposure [ __ ] off
and I got news for you if he had been
engaged encountered all those seals I
don't think they would have collectively
bitten him to death because never
haven't no like my son was with my
girl's family and they were by the in
the by the beach
they're like by the water not in the
water and their seals in there and you
know my son was freaking out he loved
seals for whatever reason he thinks
we're cool and I was like do not touch
the water cuz usually when there's old
seals in the water not far behind are
the old great white toast especially
around there they say whenever you see
seals in the water probably get out cuz
it you know the sharks didn't associate
humans seals yeah that's right get the
[ __ ] out the big fish are coming what
judgin that guy's a policy Peter it's
here on Rogen was talking about how he
doesn't swim when he does long-distance
swims between Catalina and this other
Island he stays about 200 feet off the
off the coast of this one island cuz the
elephant seals are there he doesn't get
too close though because the seals will
bite you and also because the seals swim
around there the bigger gray whites are
there I was like oh like you think being
200 yards off cuz great whites never go
there because the great whites like you
he's all the way out here that's on us
yeah you know what let's head this way
he's in the deeper ones they don't think
that sure easier for them check out the
slow skinny one right all out here by
himself
right what the [ __ ] is this cocoon I
talked to an oceanographer who said not
afraid of sharks at all I go you're not
in he goes they just don't look at his
food until they do yeah so Justin
Bieber's car broke down in a
neighborhood in LA and he stuck around
to meet fans he sung for them played
basketball and did a bunch of push-ups
goddamn that's pretty cool why boy sing
that [ __ ] you're just trying to stay
stay he's all I'll sure I'll perform
[Music]
he can sing [ __ ]
hey white boy do some push-ups hey white
boy sing right now he's all uh-huh he
said might be losing his hair he did cut
his hair recently where did he break
down it he's off what else so go get us
a goddamn Pepsi
he's by himself for an Oscar ball
playing bet it looks like a grand old
day looks like he's not terrible at
basketball either he's pretty
coordinated if you look at his dancing
yep he's clowning on these kiddos I
really got one guy goes he's white all
right white boys ain't so he's just
strolling through the hood headed
somewhere in his car broke down
mm-hmm it's kind of cool ya had it up
like a prisoner look on that picture
yeah he just hung out with some fans a
lot going on there
got some nice little tits he does have
some tit shaved his head he's a married
man now yeah he's probably [ __ ] every
girl in the world it was like you know
what I'm done apparently no prenup - no
Brina trust I just make more money I
seen one song and make it all back Lions
got a lion in a polar bear I'm looking
at his test now that's a light blue and
said it's a grizzly bear whatever all
right Chris a bear is what I meant and
then he's got more bears I think to the
right interesting
when you're seeing a man you want to
look tough I guess so yeah that's
important name it's super important
that's what else you get Jen that's
pretty cool though
yeah so on SNL Pete Davidson mocked a
Republican candidate who is a war
veteran did you see this yeah you watch
this whole thing you want to watch this
that part just like that long okay I saw
this it's my way to Brian and very fresh
this awkward chime in on this one
he is getting so much heat online he's
making fun of the way people look oh let
me see the whole bit thing okay oh I see
what's up
B what they're doing they took a segment
from the pit if you're making fun of all
candidates mm-hmm cuz all I saw was I'm
like Jesus Christ Pete and himself how
he looks to you so here we go next week
here with his first impressions of some
of the candidates it's Pete Davidson
so the midterm elections are obviously a
huge deal and after I had to move back
in my mom I started paying attention and
I realized there are some really gross
people running for office this year so
here are my first impressions this guy
is fun Rick Scott from Florida he looks
like someone tried to whittle Bruce
Willis out of a penis good joke here's a
New York guy Peter King I actually don't
know a lot about him except he looks
like if a cigar came to life this guy's
kind of cool a Dan French Shah be
surprised to hear he's a congressional
candidate from Texas and not a hit man
in a porno movie
great joke here's the problem here's a
Democrat so I look fair give me that
like Cuomo guy there is yeah Cuomo
he looks like a guy that's sleeping with
your mom but stays overnight needs
breakfast with you in his boxers is that
it that's it so they're mad they made
fun of a guy who lost his eye this is
this is this is okay first of all those
lines were written for him he's also
reading on a cue card over here they
were all hilarious number three when
he's saying whatever he's not he knows
he's aware as a comedian that that might
be you know but but by the way if you're
a veteran and like that we don't have to
treat you with kid gloves it's comedy
it's comedy he does look like a hit man
from a porno that's hilarious
that's hilarious you're allowed to make
fun of everybody if they're running for
office and he's not being in my
opinion that's not saying that if you
lose your eye or you lose there's
nothing fun or that he's not doing that
he's not doing that I agree I think this
is all but this is virtual sit this is
virtue signalling and what happens is
other people they get brownie points by
by acting outraged and more American
than he does and more protrude Stan he
does also I don't buy it
do you understand like I I'm a patriot
too
I support our veterans true to until
two-speed Davidson you know so does
people open wrote you know Pete
Davidson's father was a firefighter and
died in September laughs there you go
so his level of kind of Compassion's
different so like he he makes references
to jokes of his father died anger so his
context is diffic also he's a comedian
and he's also just have a bad bone in
his body
have you ever met Pete Dave now he's
amazing I like the nicest guy ever he's
good
he's a good-looking dude and that those
were hilarious jokes all of them were
hilarious so if you if you if that's if
I don't think anything's off-limits how
about that I agree especially if you're
gonna run for governor and if he's made
sure that way it's not he's not making
he's not being not it would be a little
weird if he by the way goes pressure on
PDF is no apology needed
yeah it'd be a little bit different if
he just think about him made fun of him
for losing Zhai during war yeah but no
he's making fun of a bunch of different
politicians this guy having Thurman
[ __ ] iPads yeah and the guy's a
badass anyway I'm sure he's fine I think
yeah I think came outside yeah he's fine
he's a man he went through war and lost
his eye
Queenie's they were making a thing of
your jokes you know give me a break this
this do you know how I feel about I love
Pete Davis and what else you got oh all
right so let's go with this so the CEO
or the the head of Twitter is
considering removing the like button why
because it's incentivizes you to like to
want to do it it doesn't incentivize a
conversation he feels like conversations
should be more deeper instead of just
going occasionally I like it you've got
worst engaged yeah but people obviously
freaking out I'm with Kanye when he had
a good point I think they should get rid
of
followers I think this should make it
undisclosed hmm not for us or for
grown-ass people before kids who idiot
that's an interesting idea but a lot of
people make their money off of not take
a market away right well now it wouldn't
though cuz you know I make money off my
suppose me or let's say someone makes my
after social media you can do it easily
because you can't figure out all the
number but they would know the
conversion same with our pockets when
there's ads on this they know very well
if this works exactly we don't have to
tell me the exact no I was about to say
that I was about to say you you would
they'd figure out ways to get the exact
numbers for sure private yeah but you
don't need it you don't need people feel
bad about themselves because they don't
have 500,000 followers and this kid does
or this for the kids it's Trouble Man
sure they've their whole worlds in
social media and then there's now
there's a numerical value on your worth
that's not good in high school I agree
with you on that I don't think it's good
at all we're figuring this whole space
out still realize now dangerous how
great it is but also how dangerous yeah
man you and I have kids so that's my
kids are my daughters ten she's gonna
get into this already she's getting a
phone soon her friends have phones oh
yeah right so it's like what else get
Jen um here's an update on that tunnel
remember the boring tunnel that Elon
Musk is making here's footage of it if
you guys want to see it it's really
quick too so 34 seconds yeah subway it's
a lot bigger than I thought I was gonna
be like the smaller to change to 200
miles I think it's a tube subway huh
yeah it looks pretty sweet though Brian
I can be the first guy to do it though
huh I'll probably wait this is the
tester is there someone in that that's
just a camera on the camera that thing's
[ __ ] flying that makes you feel a
little sick it's almost done here and it
goes into the ghost roll company Jesus
Christ
and then well it looks a nice one to get
to there there you are oh it's pretty
cool if you do all that town uh it's
opening yeah just that little to the
tester am
but if that goes well well that goes
well then they'll have to get through
the Los Angeles and Sacramento
bureaucracy to finance so dig a hole
from here to LA I'll look forward to
that the first of never that's gonna
come out like 30 years
be cool for my kid I guess yes I've seen
about what at his age you know so in 16
years from now our gas-powered cars
doing me cool I think that more and more
every company's coming out with electric
technology I know I wonder if they're
make them illegal like I think in theirs
Sweden Switzerland I think that you you
can't have guessed about cars anymore
there's somewhere there's a banning them
like when they do that here I seem about
my car I'm never getting rid of my RS
right my gt3 RS I'm Mike Godwin in like
20 years I might gonna be allowed to
drive this thing or some [ __ ] it's gonna
come I might be dead when it does come
but bring up zermat whistling oh the
horn let me see what hump before you do
it let me these country are banning
gas-powered vehicles by 21 40 40 there's
someone who's already banned it bring up
Norway Netherlands only so much I was
starting 2025 Wow yeah it's headed that
direction a bit of a bummer if you never
work help the [ __ ] Rev of a bad cell
electric food they need to and everyone
sits at a concrete timeline China has
some dirty air yeah it's only a matter
of time in bring up Zermatt Switzerland
I went there as a boy Zermatt
Switzerland and it's a ski city zer
other yeah and at least when I was there
no cars were allowed in the entire
valley only horse and buggy oh cool it
looks like the town from the movie
frozen it's so beautiful let me ask you
some brand do you want to build a
snowman
you want to build a snowman look at that
that's the Matterhorn right there it's
what's called paradise on earth it's
cold oval all in but in the winter my
paradise bro it's so set up for you to
be cozy and warm
and then you ski and it's the best
restaurants in the world and all that
stuff got a half cup together in Ha
ckets oh yeah it's not that hard you
want to go on a most incredible ski
vacation of your life you'd go to sur ma
well what if I don't want to be around
snow in the summer the nice unbelievable
you wanna bet snowman you'd love it
Switzerland is a very special flex like
Breckenridge we have a nicer oh yeah the
Swiss Alps I'm just not into skiing
snowboarding I grew up doing it you know
your father hates moving [ __ ] I hate see
ya didn't snow now you like what does it
do you hate the the gear and getting up
there I don't like any rock you I know
all day I'm the same lifts then I just
take them off and stop around when I
wanna get hot cocoa in a meal 15 layers
you got the scrawny yeah driving the
[ __ ] snow on the way bring in line for
the chairlift ah nightmare not for me
night look I'm at the top now I'm gonna
ski down I'll do it four times a day I
got my workout and leave do you want to
build a snowman in summer summer I will
just get you this is wrong and I have
trouble with me it's from last week but
we didn't get to it that Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence are going for a number
three for bad boys what did you guys
watch bad boys you guys enjoy bad boys
well didn't watch one or two watch I
wanted to know never did Ram your
[ __ ] face and that might be fun I
think two is better than one
yeah Carlo it's been quiet for a while
that's another thing there's a reason
for that
um are they shoot it looks like they're
on Santa Monica there or is that Miami
that looks like [ __ ] Venice I was
like what the but their last one they
were in Miami so they might still be in
my implant and I'll be able to tell you
Mike Lowrey that's Miami I'm telling
y'all this is crazy wait wait see the
yellow building behind it's official
official baby
it's official no that's it no more y'all
y'all can't handle no more that yeah
well Smith excited I don't care at all
but that's the 51 channel Rachel I don't
see movies till they hit demand with my
son I'm never at the movies but I do
want to see that Queen movie came out I
think right follow me and rhapsodies
right here it's great our trailer yeah
Hale came out six months ago but the
thing is is I heard they don't talk
about him being gay in it I heard they
don't touch on sexuality at all wow
that's pretty lame zone that's super
lame cuz he sucked all the day yeah
which is why he died yes not rami malek
sing or do they superimpose Freddie's
voice well apparently he doesn't sound
like [ __ ] the lead sing but he can't
sing though yeah watch it that's how we
got the that's how we got the gig you
know I hate that scene in front of them
I didn't yeah cuz there's an audition
tape yet to send your audition to Queen
and then Zim would produce that to
approve it I guess when he sat down with
them they didn't see it so like sing now
on the spot need to sing can the city's
gonna win an Oscar for this that's the
rumor
my I know his fancy dress right I want
some chompers like his bro these are my
favorite kind of movie I can't work my
fav for long trailer huh is this the
full movie or cuz I'm all set
wow it looks great I've seen it now it's
too long the trailer doesn't look good
yeah me too man it's it's gonna be sick
I think greatest frontman of all time
all time right I think the greatest rock
voice and rock and roll and I think the
greatest frontman of all time better
than Robert Plant better than the lead
singer of journey did the second best
voice or maybe tie is pin ah Steve Perry
but I don't even think Steve Perry had
the voice that Freddie Mercury had III
don't think you know damn he looked very
silly he put those they had the same
they have the same jawline yep yeah the
loin yet do you see any that chin ID
there there again some backlash about
the sexuality in the movie I didn't see
that but google it sexuality is always
something yeah people are upset about it
maybe it wasn't gay enough you know yeah
you know he was in the closet then he
got AIDS you know back pan which is my
generation you were told to keep it
under wraps cuz you wouldn't sell that's
those the the thought was back then huh
you were an actor you kept it under
wraps when you were a singer you kept it
on the wraps you couldn't be outwardly
gay oh wow look at that Ellis John he
was a huge thing when he talked about it
he casually said I mom sexual and it was
like what I'm a sexual I was like a it
was like that's all anybody was talking
about back then dude how about Ricky
Martin yeah talking about a pure
dimepiece women are like what the [ __ ]
yep and I remember when my friend I told
me and I said I didn't believe it yeah
I'm like the [ __ ] well there's nothing
gay about that man I know
besides tight pants and his dancing and
yeah but other than that yeah he's
[ __ ] well you see how
shaaka he was such a heartthrob to women
and a lot of his hot economic you know
that was his family future was wrapped
up in that idea yes so when you say
you're gay it's your you know he's a
good actor to men he's talented
so was it was a response to the trailer
because they didn't show it much in the
trailers just a trailer no I have no
problem with it then all right yeah yeah
I can't wait for that movie I might try
and see it this week babysitter what
else we got Jen this one that dude from
Australia that swallowed a slug in his
backyard off of a dare cuz they were
drunk so they this is not Australia this
guy was with his friends his friends
like you know you stoop with your
friends I've been there yeah like do I
dare to eat that slug someone actually
offered me to eat a slug when I was in
college I was like not even a slug
because I don't want to kill it nothing
I don't eat it do you want to kill it
this dude ate it and died yeah because
what was on years later ill it's like
some rat roundworm disease so eight
years later because he curable oh if you
get to it nope I think so
and it was in 2010 right so is eight
years play have you seen the video
mm-hmm he is I mean he it [ __ ] him up
and you get rack rat lungworm disease is
this a video talking about no I think it
was on Twitter they had a video of the
kid like I mean he was completely
paralyzed
and like just a shell of himself you
mean it right I went right afterwards
yeah right off you want a shock Jesus
that's great done a [ __ ] your buddy's
just bullshitting that Katie eat this
rugby player he went paralyzed dude well
that's his oh shoot I see him right
there yeah I mean your time back from
eating a saw Brian
no it's there was the [ __ ] slug a
whole group of family and friends who
support look so cute do men an
extraordinary young man who eight years
ago at the age of 19 and a slug on a
silly dare and had his life changed
forever
like most young men their age 19 year
old Sam Ballard in his mates felt they
were invincible but one night in 2010
shattered that illusion he's in a coma
for forum 20 think every year having a
bit of a red wine Appreciation Night
trying to act as grown-ups than a slug
came crawling across here and then the
conversation came up you know should I
eat it and off Sam went bang that what
happened in the following days strapping
rugby playing Sam complained of severe
pain in his legs
was it MS which is what my husband had
but they cleared him all from that and
that's when he said all we are we were
walking him down to the ward he was in a
wheelchair he said I had a slug could it
be that and I went oh but doctors found
Sam had been infected with rat lungworm
which can be carried by slugs he was
scared
so you know as a mom all you want to do
is reassure them as far as I'm concerned
he didn't do anything wrong it was just
a silly thing but Sam and his loved ones
have paid an enormous price from bad
luck man bad luck I mean I just talked
that up they're just bad luck he had a
bad slug you can eat a lot of slugs and
they're usually fine you want price was
a sick slug this slug was shitty slow
kid radd on them
that sucks and he passed away Friday
right I think so man I don't watch that
[ __ ] sterile is terrible I've done
some stupid bets with my buddies yeah
that's horrible man [ __ ] slugs bro let's
kill all slugs I like a slug man it's
cute to me
I don't even sit their eyes their
antennas it can go up and down up and
down it's their eyes thought so so I
didn't know slugs suck most of them
don't this was an evil slug shitty slug
yeah they're hung out with rats you got
your slug test tested test all slugs man
they always think ah student now left
paralyzed after clay he's up a thousand
things Christ well they ain't a flower
let's end on a positive one I'm all
weekend my grandmother's French I'm a
pin prick for my rose she got blood
poisoning Jesus Christ everybody dies
well we tried our best man is that it
that's it dude we're heading on don't
touch slugs well I mean guys know it all
Kelly ranked Tamera's least like TV news
say you before back blackface oh wow
that's better than this look thing
alright so that's better
least liked because women hate her cuz
she's pretty
yeah and that well just women here cuz
men pray like yeah or is that the
liberal news kind of going bad on q
score's company the entertainment
industry's most use indicator of popular
rock off I like her so [ __ ] you I don't
really listen to her in everybody I've
never listened earlier I don't know if I
like her she's older yeah yeah that's it
that's it all righty man hey B you know
I'm a rocket on our next show tomorrow
Wednesday whenever decided to do it but
I the new firing the kid collab with
roots a fight that hand-stitched
bomber jacket that I'd rocked at the
Tommy stores a great boss they only made
a hundred of them i well i ipod at the
air i tried to get bring it up chin i
tried only made a hundred of them it's a
special package they come with the abbot
kinney Fight Club sweats calves in tidge
soft ass sweats the abbot kinney Fight
Club gym bag and then that hand-stitched
dude that's Guam her jacket as well
that's a major show in an edition and
there's so few many so the price point
is higher you can get them now I think T
fat kid comp but also roots a fight
they're doing a pre-sale they will ship
in January but they're only releasing a
hundred that's it once they sell up
they're never coming back
look at that that's why the price points
so high there's super exclusive super
limited edition everything's handmade
hand stitched the logos everything
everything you get them now for pre-sale
like these are got a gun I don't even
have one it's meet anybody in here
probably cuz they were like you know
what he's 51 he won't he's gonna hurt
it's not for him it's gonna hurt sale
they said that you might have said it
behind my back
how you might have gotten out over those
not for Brian Lee the sweats do and then
you look at the dick diver badge that we
was talk about how were temper saying
Jessie judge Jessie I want that I want
the sweats and a medium sweats and a
medium make the the crotch area I need
that area to breathe that can't be
medium that can't be helped dobra in the
remote
orange Porsche there's been so much
thought that went into this it's the
lining the jackets orange for my lava
orange Porsche
I've purple now so yeah it's [ __ ] up
but whatever I love it yeah I mean I
can't wear it don't have that stupid oh
you looked good in this the first thing
I said I I didn't know you got that
jacket I love it I love it I was gonna
wear it today
I forgot so I'm gonna wear Wednesday
okay yep but you can get them now for
presale like said there's I think
there's only a hundred 150 and after
they're gone they're gone forever
t fat K calm or roots of fight calm
we'll have them get them a great gift
for finding a kid fan but high price
point because they're all handmade super
limited other than that this week I am
off and then the following week November
bring up my date gender like punchline
man Oh punchline Sacramento Friday and
Saturday only two shows Friday to show
Saturday those are almost sold out that
was November 16th and 17th and after
that I'm in New York City at one of my
favorite clubs Gotham comedy club
November 30th December 1st Alice after
that I'm in New Mexico and then the big
old grin hog oh so January 19th Showtime
special one hour two shows only Saturday
have some friends you guys might know
open up for me
San Diego California Spreckels theatre
January 19th
take it that T fat K dot-com we will see
you guys later in the week
this is the finally kid we're out